hello everyone hey
um i just love this movie it was so
beautiful i loved all the performances
um i know margot that you produced this
film
under your company lucky chap
entertainment so how does it feel
knowing that all these amazing projects
that you've worked on like dreamland
are have just been so well received by
people
it's amazing and i definitely have to
say off the bat we also produced with
automatic
um bkj and ryan our partners in crime
here
so uh it's amazing this is one of our
earlier projects and
um i feel like we've done we've done
quite like a variation of things so far
and the fact that each movie has found
its audiences is great it just kind of
says like
when you follow your gut and you
gravitate towards something
you'll find seeing something specific
there and that specificity i think
is what other people latch on to
sometimes so this again is
is different to our other projects but
we're incredibly proud of it
and i'm just so happy that everyone's
gonna see it now because
miles is like an insanely talented
filmmaker
and finn is so insanely talented as an
actor as well and so i feel like
we've been sitting on this and i'm like
i just want the world to see it and now
they get to it's great
miles you uh got to premiere this film
back at tribeca so how does it feel now
like margot saying
that everyone gets to see this film now
it's so exciting
it's it's so exciting it's like you know
it's
it seems like it's gotten harder and
harder to release a movie in the last
um two years and so i was like uh
have been i have i've been so excited
for people to see it and now that it's
finally happening there's it's sort of
it's surreal because it is that first
time it was kind of like um
of passing on this thing that was such
an incredibly
um special and intimate experience to
make
um it really was you know
a small movie in in terms of our our
means and
but there was so uh there was so much
support and love and like vulnerability
on set that i really made
uh it really yeah really made a real
impression on me and so now
being able to actually show it and and
hope that some of that translates into
unbelievable work that that the whole
cast did but that these two did
you know specifically it was like it's
really amazing to see i mean from the
we did so many chemistry reads
specifically margot red with so many
you know people because the part was so
important right eugene
um the part that been played that needed
to be kind of perfect in a way
and to see first of the producer margot
sort of like
commitment to going there and doing it
and really
being um doing doing the work to find
the actor and then when we found him and
being able to see them play off each
other has been
yeah amazing finn how does it feel to
hear all that you're getting praise from
margot
they they search long and hard for a kit
for you you know how does it feel like
did you instantly feel a connection to
eugene
um yeah 100 you know i got like like
these guys
say you know we we got together and it
felt very quickly like we're a big
family and we're all supporting each
other and um
and being on set and and doing that
makes makes our job so much easier and
all we have to do is
is perform and it felt like the
environment where
showing up and giving 100 every day was
was respected and appreciated by
everyone on set
so um i i could just reciprocate all of
those comments and say that these guys
were
the best to work with and we had so much
fun so i'm so excited for people to see
that and hopefully it comes across on
screen
you know back in the day there seemed to
be this aura around people who
did bad things like bonnie and clyde
what do you think it is about
um a connection that people had to these
types of figures
i mean i think there are lots of i mean
it's that kind of uh uh like superheroes
fiction type thing that i i definitely
was
attracted to these was the reason i was
attracted to these stories
and this one in particular um i think
the
you get an element of it early on where
where
eugene's reading his his magazines and
his and his comic books and you
you get a sense that he kind of yearns
for this this other world and these
this uh this kind of you know this this
yearning to explore
and he and he kind of gets that so i
think what what attracted him to this
life was is what attracts
all of us and all of the audiences to
these types of stories
margaret what do you think it is about
these types of figures and especially
the characters that you played that
there's just kind of this
this aura around them for people yeah i
mean it's funny that you asked that
because
i think both of our characters are kind
of looking for escape in some ways or
immortality i mean for alison i think
she looks up to these characters because
they become this myth they become this
legend and you can't kill an
a legend or a myth you live on you're
not going to be forgotten i think
in the backdrop of the dust bowl where
every it's just such an unforgiving
harsh landscape and time and i mean
literally buildings were eroding away
before their eyes and just
there were nothing more than dust that
would just you know disappear and be
forgotten forever i think that's quite a
confronting thing that people were
facing and i think
definitely the impotence for her
character was was a legacy
to live on and and due to circumstances
uh she's kind of in a pretty desperate
situation but she comes across
this guy who is also looking
for some looking for escape but i think
looking for it in a different way i
think he's looking through it with
innocent eyes and i think
he's definitely uh romanticizing the
idea of this life and comes to see in
the movie that
it's a it's a pretty yeah he's going to
see some pretty ugly things it's it's
not what it seems and that's
kind of the growing up part of the story
that's that's
you know going from innocence you know
an innocent childhood to an adulthood
and being
kind of exposed to the parts of life
that are less pleasant so
it's all of that yeah i'm glad you asked
that because it's absolutely the theme
of the film
yeah um well i do have to ask you
basically won halloween 2020 by dressing
up as ginger spice so i just have to ask
have you ever thought about producing or
starring in a film about spice girls
this is just my dream come true what do
you think i have yeah
that was quick that was really good
you kidding i love the spice girls love
them finn may i ask which slice girl
would you be
oh uh i don't i haven't thought about it
let me get back to you on that one
honestly it's like pumpkin spice
pumpkin spice and real quick because i
got the rap is there any update on tank
girl
it was like my favorite movie in the 90s
that's so funny you're a second person
to ask that
no miles miles and i are you know both
obsessed with the
with the tank girl comics and um i
personally actually have never seen the
movie but
yeah at this stage nothing more than
rumors i'm afraid but
uh we definitely could talk for hours
about how much we love pink girl
amazing thanks so much guys congrats on
the film